Wow thank you it's a big crowd I was
actually at a I did a speech for a law
firm in New York about a month ago and
the crowd was way bigger than I expected
and I was about to take go up to the
podium I asked the the partner at the
firm I said how did you get so many
people to come to this thing and he said
oh that's easy we told them you were Ben
Bernanke so I don't know who they told
you it's coming tonight but my name is
Matt Taibbi I'm a reporter formerly of
Rolling Stone magazine now with first
look media and I'll explain I guess what
that myself what that is later but first
I obviously just want to thank all the
folks who brought me here Kay and Burton
her husband Burkhart and Craig from the
library and everybody who had a hand in
helping me come here today okay is that
better
all right so I have a new speech for you
all tonight because I've actually I had
my a speech that I had written for this
book tour I've actually used it a few
times and I am I threw it out this
morning I was dissatisfied with it I
thought it turned out to be not entirely
honest and someone coming try to tell
you all a little bit of a different
story about the back story for this book
because there's sort of an interesting
backstory to this book the the what
happened with the with the writing of
the divide was that it was sort of a
classic example it began that's kind of
a classic example of what can happen
when journalists get lazy and I was a
classic example of that phenomenon and
this this book very nearly turned out to
be a lot worse than it is because of
some things that had happened
my life leading up to the writing of
this book so I should really go all the
way back to the beginning which is and
because six or seven years ago I had no
knowledge about anything in the
financial services sector about which
this book is significantly concerned I
didn't know anything about Wall Street
and I can date practically to the day
the moment when my career kind of took
this bizarre turn from being somebody
who essentially just made fun of
politicians for a living that's that's
really what I did I was like a humorous
who would go in the campaign trail and
make jokes about people from being that
to being this internationally recognized
expert on white-collar crime which is to
this day still funny to me but this all
really goes back and I remember the day
BK and I know the date because it was a
it was an important day in American
history it was September 3rd of 2008 I
was in Minnesota
I guess st. Paul at the Xcel Energy
Center covering the Republican
convention does everybody remember Sarah
Palin's speech yeah here so I was there
at the at the convention and I was
covering that speech and I remember
sitting as people were going nuts for
this speech thinking well this is
amazing this is going to be a this
person's going to be an important
phenomenon in American politics and I
was trying to formulate what thing I was
going to say about this and and trying
to come up with some funny angle on it
and I went back after the speech to the
filing room how many people are
journalists in this room do we have any
a couple okay so the filing room is
always like this windowless hole that
they find in any event in any location
where they stick all the journalists and
you're supposed to write your story
after the event and basically this
little cage where they keep the
journalists and so I went back there and
I was with all the other campaign
reporters and I logged onto the internet
and I was
sitting down to write my Sarah Palin
story when I look on the internet and I
see all these news stories about how the
International economy is melting down
and I was completely mystified by it and
I was reading I was trying to figure out
what was going on and all I could get
was that it had something to do with
mortgages and who knows what it was and
there are all these venerable companies
that we're going to go out of business
tomorrow unless we gave them you know
100 trillion dollars or something like
that and I remembered looking to my
right and there was seated there a very
prominent I'll just call him a reporter
for a prominent East Coast news
publication and I said to him dude are
you reading the news like the world is
ending and do you know anything about
this or do you know what a subprime
mortgages and I remember he was typing
already and he looked up to me and he
was goes I got like whatever right like
that was his response
he didn't care at all he gave me the
whole thing everyone seen the movie
clueless
yeah like whatever so I was I was deeply
disturbed by this moment because
obviously journalists our job is to
pretend to be experts about things we
know absolutely nothing about but this
was this was going far beyond that here
we were in the middle of a presidential
election that was becoming more and more
about the economy and the economy was
melting down and not one of us had even
the faintest clue about the causes of it
and the more I read in the newspapers
the less I understood all the news
stories about the causes of the 2008
financial crisis were written in this
totally impenetrable camouflaging jargon
where it was impossible for an ordinary
person to make heads or tail head or
tail of what it was actually going on
and I got some word ahead of time from
my editors that as soon as the election
was over that I was going to be assigned
to cover this phenomenon and to write a
story about what the causes of the crash
were which
course sent me into this terminal panic
basically because I could not understand
the story for the life of me and now I
was going to have to become again an
expert at length in Rolling Stone
because we don't do anything you know at
300 words it's always 5,000 words so I
was imagining 5,000 words of ignorance
and so I started journalists are
basically like professional test
Crammers you know we don't know anything
we try to like learn it all by the next
morning by studying up and so I got all
these books you know I started at the
very beginning you know wealth of
nations you know Milton Friedman Hayek
you know all the econ books and I was
calling up you know Wall Street analysts
sort of at random like cold calling them
and saying saying things like just tell
me something about something you know
like that that was how I knew so little
that that I didn't know what questions
to ask so I just sort of made general
inquiries hoping that somebody would
help me figure out what was going on and
nobody could it was all the same stuff
nobody can make any sense of the whole
subprime mortgage thing for me and then
finally I got very lucky and I found
this guy who was a former trader for
Credit Suisse who had an interesting
sideline hobby which is that he made
these very mean and funny cartoons about
the banks on the Internet in his spare
time and so I figured if this guy can do
cartoons then he can probably help me
and he took me to lunch and I start Matt
maniacally explaining to him my problem
that I'm three weeks away from a
deadline and I don't know anything and
he he says to me you know your your
problem is that you're looking at this
all the wrong way
you're thinking about this is an
economic story and it's not it's a crime
story and then everything from that in
that moment everything started to become
crystal clear to me and he started to
explain to me about what the mortgage
scam really
and essentially what it was was a much
huger to scale version of the trademark
counterfeiting scam
we were actually in Chinatown we were
having this discussion he pointed out
the window at some people who were
selling phony Prada bags out of a out of
a trunk on the streets of Chinatown and
he goes he'd see that and I said yes and
he goes well it's the same thing except
instead of fake handbags it's fake
triple-a mortgages and he starts telling
me this whole thing about how what the
banks were essentially doing was they
were lending billions of dollars to
these fly-by-night subprime companies
like countrywide which in turn were
fanning out into middle class and
lower-income neighborhoods giving
mortgages to anyone with a pulse I
remember I remember talking to one
mortgage broker who worked for a
countrywide like company let's say and
he he told me that he his strategy was
to go to the 7-eleven at night and hang
around the beer cooler and that was how
he found customers for his subprime
mortgages and they would hand out these
mortgages to anybody and everybody and
of course they didn't mind doing that
because they weren't gonna hold on to
them for more than ten minutes as soon
as the ink was dry and these mortgages
they sold them back to the banks the
banks in turn took all these mortgages
basically threw them in a big vat chop
them up into securities they bullied the
ratings agencies who of course are
financially dependent upon the banks
they bullied them into giving high
triple-a ratings for some of these
securities and then they would turn
around and sell these securities to
institutional investors like pension
funds foreign trade unions foreign hedge
funds so if you boil the whole thing
down to its essence what they were
really doing is they were creating huge
masses of highly risky essentially
worthless debt and using bogus math to
turn them into triple-a rated securities
and then selling them to say state
pension funds so they were robbing old
ladies that's really all it was it was
the same it's the same thing as selling
phony handbags or phony Rolex watches
except that it was in this case phone
phony mortgages and so I was fascinated
by this and I was completely hooked and
this new approach to looking at the
subject
I thought gave me a an approach to
covering the topic that nobody else had
and I did a couple of stories the first
story that I did was about AIG and the
causes of the AIG bailout because one of
the interesting side lights of all this
was that while many of these companies
were creating all these bad loans a lot
of them got smart and realized that all
of this was unsustainable so as they're
selling all these bad loans out into the
world they started to bet against them
at the same time and where did they bet
against them they went to companies like
AIG where they essentially bought
insurance policies against their own
product and what they didn't know is
that they would ultimately blow up their
own bookie
by doing this and that's the backstory
to the AIG bailout which is that AIG was
crushed under the weight of its own
portfolio and it's fine in its financial
products portfolio which involved a
number of these sort of credit default
swap bets against the subprime market so
essentially these guys bet against their
own product they blew up their bookie
and then when their bookie was going to
go under they went to the federal
government and said this is intolerable
we needed a federal bailout so that we
can be paid off on the bets we made
against our own product which is great
it's brilliant actually when you think
about it so I was writing about all
these things and I became completely
fascinated by the subject and and over
the course of about a year and a year
and a half I became more literate and in
the jargon and and I learned to be able
to read the Wall Street Journal and not
and not you know be completely mystified
by the language they were using and just
sort of read between the lines of a lot
of a lot of things that we're going on
in the business understand the bailouts
all that and I am
i occupied this kind of strange space in
the media because there really if you
think about it there was no place in the
American media where anybody was
explaining anything that was going on in
the financial services sector for the
rest of America like the financial press
is written for people in finance if you
pick up the Financial Times or The Wall
Street Journal and you're somebody who
lives you know not in lower Manhattan
and has a job that's unconnected to
finance you'll find it very hard to read
most of the material has anyone ever
tried to read you know the Wall Street
Journal from cover to cover and made
sense of it I mean it's it's a it's a
very difficult exercise so there was
this whole territory that was left open
for a journalist who wanted to do the
work of essentially translating what was
going on and high finance for the rest
for these mass audiences it was I
thought of it after a while as being a
little bit like that moment where you
know the Bible had been in Latin forever
and now somebody was going to put it in
English and how revolutionary was that
and and it was really interesting it was
a fascinating thing that I got this
amazing response to the stories and it
really it energized my career I had a
tremendous intellectual challenge that
you know previously the work was was in
a way it was existentially kind of
disturbing to me just going out in the
campaign trail and making snide comments
about politicians was I really adding
anything by doing that probably not you
know and here right here was this work
that I thought was much more important
and and it was it was very personally
satisfying to me so I started to I wrote
one book about it which called grift
topia which which did fairly well and I
started to get more offers to write
another book and this was right around
the time of the Occupy protests and I
remember thinking that there was a
persistent theme and all the stories
that I had written which was that no
matter what the caper was whether it was
subprime mortgage fraud whether it was
robo-signing whether it was a situation
like Jefferson County Alabama where a
bunch of banks had sold these toxic swap
deals to you know sort of mystified
locals who didn't know what they were
getting into in fact banks might have
even bribed some of the local officials
into taking these swap deals whatever it
was
nobody ever got punished nobody got
indicted nobody went to jail and I
thought well that's an easy subject I'll
just write about that like you know
here's all these people who have done
tremendously socially destructive things
across the country and not one of them
is being punished for it and and I'm
talking to prosecutors and lawyers and
they're showing me that all this be that
a large percentage of this behavior is
criminal and that it could easily be
prosecuted but it's not being prosecuted
and I start hearing things like well
after the SNL crisis they they put 800
people in jail and what are we doing now
we're not putting anybody in jail and so
this was interesting to me and I thought
this will be easy I'll write this up
it'll take me six months to write this
story up I'll just take a whole bunch of
chapters and I'll write one story after
another about each one of these capers
and the punchline at the end of each
chapter will be the same nobody goes to
jail and people will read it and they'll
be upset and the book will sell and
somewhat cynically I thought this would
be an easy thing for me to do and this
is where I want to talk about laziness
because I had gotten lazy I the whole
experience of having gone through that
stage of my career where I was doing
this thing and I was it was
intellectually challenging and
interesting I had really stopped asking
questions about a lot of things and I
just when you start doing things because
they're easy you can get into trouble
really really quickly and my you know so
just out of just to do my due diligence
at the time I decided that it was
important just to cover my bases
toric Lee as I tell this infuriating
story of people who commit fraud in the
billions and don't go to jail for it
that I should find out a little bit
about who does go to jail in America and
why and and how the criminal justice
system works and that I would have to
re-educate myself about yet another
thing where I wasn't an expert and so I
started so traveling across the country
and spending a lot of time in courts and
in police stations talking to people who
had been in prisons talking to immigrant
lawyers and I was completely overwhelmed
by how much I didn't know about what
ordinary people went through when they
had to go through the criminal justice
system you know I was sort of happily
you know living through this whole
period of my life and in a weird kind of
twisted way the financial crisis had
been a huge boon to me personally and I
hadn't been paying attention to this
other thing that apparently had been
going on for decades in this country
that I didn't know anything about and
just to give you an example like one of
the first stories I learned about when I
was in New York I went to a public
defender's office and I found out about
a mentally disabled 13 year old
african-american boy who had been picked
up by the police thrown in the back of a
squad car
and told that he couldn't go home that
night until he helped the officers find
an illegal gun and basically this this
young young person didn't know that he
could just get out of the car at any
time the officers told them that you
know their lieutenant was going to get
them in trouble if this little boy
didn't help them and the little boy
finally tells the policeman that there's
a gun in his grandmother's house and so
you can all guess the ending the police
descend upon the grandmother's house you
know on mass they arrest everybody there
the grandmother the kids brother the kid
they're all dragged down to the police
station
and I start to hear that this is not an
uncommon circumstance that people are
just sort of swept up all the time there
is this thing they called a crime squad
in New York and it's dedicated solely to
finding guns and they do extraordinary
things to try to get people to give them
information including this and I started
to contrast this behavior to you know
how we for instance pursue a high-level
offender who might have defrauded people
out of billions of dollars and you think
about the aggressiveness is going after
a 13 year old kid and the total
passiveness that we that we bring to
going after this other part of the
population and the I started to get a
little bit more emotionally involved
then I remember I went to Georgia after
that some time not long after that and I
heard a story of a woman who was an
undocumented immigrant this stories in
the book actually she went to the she
got in a car and she went to the
supermarket to buy groceries for her
kids she gets rear-ended on the way home
and she begs and pleads with the person
who she's involved in the accident with
an undocumented immigrant if the police
come I'll be deported I won't see my
kids ever again and the woman who
actually hit her was an immigrant
herself from India and she didn't listen
and the woman was taken away and thrown
in jail and despite and over the
protestations of the local ministry who
had known this woman from church because
she had been in the country for ten
years this woman went through the whole
process of deportation proceedings she
ultimately prevailed in the case but it
took quite a long time she was separated
from her kids from work for a long time
similarly I met a woman in Los Angeles
this story is also in the book her
husband was involved in a fight with
some gang members in his neighborhood he
was actually a working man he was mad
about these guys selling drugs on his
corner
he told them to move off the corner away
from his kids he got in a fight
police brought everybody in they
deported everybody and the woman never
saw her husband again and so now she's
left with six six kids all by herself
doesn't have any means of taking care of
them and they all get evicted they're
living in a car but it turns out that
you can't have a car legally in the
state of Los Angeles if you're
undocumented because you're not allowed
to have a driver's license she gets
arrested for that the fine that she has
to pay initially is $1700
that's another persistent feature of
this is that whenever you start to see
fines in this segment of society they're
always out sighs they're always
incredibly high compared to the ability
of people to pay she tells the judge
that she can't pay that much money so he
sent this is it her to 170 hours of
community service and she starts talking
about how she would have to bring each
of her kids to school on the public bus
system every day and then she would go
to her job cleaning houses and then at
the end of the day she would pick her
kids up by bus again and then go to a
soup kitchen where she would do her
community service until past midnight
with all of her kids running around and
then she would get a few hours of sleep
and the whole process would repeat
itself over and over again and and she
talked about crying herself to sleep at
night every night for three months then
in New York I met another guy named
Andrew Brown his story is also in the
book I was in a law office on another
story waited to hear another talked to a
lawyer about a different case when this
35 year old african-american bus driver
comes in and he tells me that he's he
had been arrested for what he called
obstructing pedestrian traffic and I
didn't know what that was I asked him to
show me the summons and he pulls out
this wrinkled piece of pink paper and he
shows it to me and sure enough on it is
written obstructing pedestrian traffic
it turns out that he had come home
in the morning after driving a shuttle
bus he works for a casino company and he
shovels people all over the New York
area and he drove home he comes home and
the police see him standing in front of
his own apartment building with his
friend and they're listening to music
sharing a set of headphones and the
whole purpose of the new statistics
based policing strategies in New York is
to stop people for any reason whatsoever
and what they're looking for again are
guns or warrants or fugitives basically
and they stop these two and the
ostensible reason was that they were
quote-unquote obstructing pedestrian
traffic even though it was 1:00 in the
morning there was nobody else on the
street and they were just standing there
in front of their own our own own
apartment of course neither of them had
guns neither of them had warrants so
theoretically what they do is they throw
all the innocent people back after they
kind of throw this big net over these
communities both they they don't always
do that instead what I found out is that
in practice they just proceeded with
whatever these ridiculous little cases
are and they force people to go through
the process of either pleading to these
ridiculous offenses or fighting them out
and so Andrew had to go through months
and months and months of court
appearances where he was continually
unable to convince his own lawyer that
he was innocent of the offense of
standing in front of his own house and
they kept asking him well will you take
a $50 fine it's only $50 and he would
say no and they'd say all right fine how
about 25 and he would say no I'm not you
know I'm not guilty I'm not going to pay
this fine and I watched this whole
process from beginning to end it took
months it wasn't until the very end of
this process and the judge finally asked
the policeman on duty was there anybody
on the street that night the policeman
sheepishly admitted no there was not
your honor and he said oh well in that
case case dismissed I guess and you know
and he kind of gavels it out and Andrew
was let go and that's how long it took
for
sky to get out from under the case of
standing in front of his own house and
so I got to admit you know my sort of
white guilt ohmmeter just went through
the roof after this like I I was I had
lived in New York for ten years I had
never asked enough questions about what
was going on in the other boroughs I
never got stopped by the police for
anything and it turns out that for other
people there's a completely different
experience and so and I realized that
that's reflected very badly on on me
both as a person and as a reporter and
it also occurred to me that this had to
be there was no way to write the story
about people not going to jail for these
enormous crimes on Wall Street without
also talking about this other side of
the coin about the this this sort of
gigantic mindless punishment machine
that we have for people without means
and I the whole process of this book
became basically a gigantic
juxtaposition where I wanted what I
really wanted to do was have people go
through the same process of discovery
that I did and I figured that if people
could see these stories out side by side
over and over again that they would I
wouldn't even have to make an argument
about how unfair it all was you could
just sort of see it for yourself and
that's why that if you read this book
you know from I quote unquote literary
point of view it's sometimes not the
tightest narrative in the world there
are actually long stretches of the book
where you can see that I'm I've kind of
gotten caught up and just saying can can
you believe this happened you know and
there's they'll be like this long
passage about it somebody who's been
through this incredible experience and
then I'll finally kind of downshift from
that back into something that happened
on Wall Street and and it's it's not the
most you know structured level-headed
facile argument and
world it's really--it's it became a very
emotional exercise for me to try to put
these stories together and so so again
so that's what this whole thing is is
it's it's a big exercise in sort of
placing like stories side by side like
for instance let's you know you have a
woman who loses custody of her kids for
for accepting $800 too much in welfare
and she may also suffer a small jail
sentence in fact there was an amazing
case in Ohio involving a woman who had
told who had lied about where she lived
she claimed that she and her kids lived
with her father in a neighboring town
where they had a better school district
because she wanted the kids to go to a
better school when this came to the
attention of the authorities the judge
who was the one ruling on her fraud case
said that it would it would outraged
justice if this woman did not get a jail
sentence and so she was sentenced to 15
days in jail she ultimately got off
that's but that sort of the sidelines to
the story but again this is all just
opposed against people like Angelo
Mozilo of countrywide you think about a
person like this who created you know
billions and billions of dollars or
toxic loans and nearly blew up the
entire international economy in the
process and not only was he not charged
not only did nobody ever consider taking
his kids away from him and but the civil
case that they finally did bring against
him ended up finding him something on
the order of forty nine million dollars
most of that was covered by an insurance
policy by by Bank of America which by
then had acquired countrywide Mozilo had
earned in his time as the head of
countrywide somewhere
in the order of 450 to 500 million
dollars so he got to keep a 400 plus
million dollar fortune walk away without
doing the day in jail and sort of ride
off into the sunset with his famous tan
if you've ever seen him he's got it
isn't this boffo tan this guy and and
this is so this is the justification if
you do it's like the Woody Allen's will
be crimes and misdemeanors if you commit
a very very small crime the consequences
will be extremely severe and if you
commit you know an unbelievably massive
crime like the people at country why did
there were no consequences at all and I
just can't underscore how how completely
the activity a country ride really was
fraud in the classic sense of criminal
fraud I and I talked to a whistleblower
who worked for that company who
ironically was brought in to be a
quality control officer at the firm he
had worked at other big major American
corporations before and he tell us the
story about going to the office for the
first day and driving into the parking
lot and he sees one of the executives it
wasn't Mozilla it was like his number
two or something like that but he had a
personalized license plate that that red
fund him I and when he asked what that
meant he was told well we give mortgages
to everybody and that's what that means
in other words this was a company whose
stated policy to the point that they put
it on their vanity plates on their
luxury cars was not to do when he due
diligence on their on their home loans
and to crank out as many bad loans as
they could and sell them back to the
banks who would then again chop them up
put them in the stew and sell them to
the rest of us as triple-a rated
securities so these are the kinds of the
things that are in this book are lots of
sort of side by side stories like this
and there are a lot of things that I
learned about very basic inequities in
the system that people don't think about
a lot for example here's here a couple
of stories about a very important
phenomenon and
in this country that people don't think
about too much which is BHEL BHEL is
critically important to the whole
question of whether or not you're going
to get away with a crime in America
lawyers in courtrooms at least in New
York City they have a saying if you go
in you stay in if you get out you stay
out in other words if you survive the
bail hearing without getting and you
have enough to get out on bail then
you'll be able to fight the case and
you'll probably win if you don't if they
find a number that's high enough that
you can't pay and they even have a term
for this in New York they call it
nuisance bail where the judges and the
prosecutors actually analyze your assets
and they find out just how much it would
take to keep you in jail and they name a
number for the bail amount that is just
beyond your ability to pay if you go in
you're not going to be able to fight it
and why can't you fight it well they
have for instance in New York City and
in other places in the country a speedy
trial rule which alecky sensibly means
that they either have to bring you to
trial and bring you into court or
dismiss the case within 90 days but they
have a trick that they use to get around
that and I detail it this trick in the
book what they do is on your first court
date the prosecutors will show up in
court and I watch this happen over and
over again and they'll say that the
judge your honor we're not ready to
proceed today and the judge who always
has an overstuffed packed calendar right
there's so many crimes going through
these courtrooms that it's not like you
can reschedule for tomorrow he looks at
his calendar everything says okay well
let's let's meet again in in eight weeks
or nine weeks for ten weeks and the
defendant is rolling his eyes because he
knows he or she knows that that you know
they're going to be in jail for again
that period of time at least and the
prosecutor agrees and they go away and
then what happens the next day is the
prosecutor quietly files a document
called a certificate of readiness which
access to the tests to the court
while we were not ready to proceed
yesterday we are in fact ready to
proceed today if you had to so the court
doesn't charge 60 or 70 days of that 90
days it doesn't charge the prosecutors
that amount of time they only charge
them for one day toward that period so
even though technically you're supposed
to either be convicted or out of jail
within 90 days they can actually keep
you in jail
more or less infinitely by reusing this
process over and over again so if you
don't have enough money to get out on
bail you're going to be in there a while
and this is sort of the four corner
offensive process of misdemeanor
prosecution in in some big cities and
what happens as many defendants realized
that they could spend a lot more time
waiting to go to court than they even
would if they were convicted and
sentenced of whatever crime it is
especially if it's a misdemeanor like
prostitution or petty theft or something
like that if it's not a crime that
involves a weapon or some kind of some
kind of violent assault you're almost
certainly going to do do less time by
pleading than you would by sitting and
fighting it out and in jail so over and
over again you will see people go into
the court and either plead or you know
take an Alford plea and nolo contendere
plea and now and they end up getting out
with time served plus 10 days because
that's one of the things that happens is
as soon as they know that they can keep
you in jail they come back they start
coming to you with offers just like
Andrea Brown started getting offers for
$50 and then it was $25 or whatever it
was they start coming to people and
saying well how about time served plus
10 days or time served plus five days or
time served plus you know two hours and
a Snickers bar or whatever it is and
people you know if you've been sitting
in jail and you've got kids at home
waiting for you and you might be losing
your job or you already ab lost your job
you're going to take the deal 99 times
out of 100 and so people plead out
through these cases and now they've got
a record right and so now the next time
they
get swept up for whatever it is a the
bail is going to be higher so they're
going to have less of a chance to fight
it out and B there are enormous
consequences to even having a conviction
or even being accused of a crime I
described these two men and in the book
Anthony Odom and Michael McMichael who
this is so terrible but they were
stopped in in the South Bronx basically
for for driving a nice car the police
totally profiled them it was winter they
said that an odor of marijuana was
emanating from the vehicle you know of
course this is the middle of winter
where all the windows are rolled up how
the police detected the odor it's
impossible to say but of course they
sweep these guys up on the idea that
they smelled marijuana they don't find
any marijuana in the car but they charge
him with a marijuana possession anyway
and they're in the system for a year and
a half before the case goes away but in
that time period one of them Anthony
Odom had been applying for a job as a
driver for the MTA system and you can't
proceed with a an application for a
State job if you have a drug case
hanging over your head and so he lost a
chance at that job and so that's what
you would call a collateral consequence
of that kind of activity this person
lost an opportunity for a job just
because the cops had to meet their
numbers incidentally I learned a lot of
things about why they would sweep people
up the way policemen get promoted in
cities like New York is by the number of
guns they retrieve the number of people
they catch on warrants and by the number
of summons is their right and some in
some districts I'm sorry in some
precincts there's been evidence it's
that's that's come out where people
please me to testify that they've been
told they have to empty a pad of
summonses every month or they'll be told
if they have a squad of eight that goes
out and
morning they got to pick up eight people
before they come back to the station
house so there are quotas and I'd be
told over and over again about how how
the system works people would like
Michael and Anthony would be caught they
would first be put into a squad car the
squad covered then bring them to a van
that was somewhere in the neighborhood
where all the other people that who have
been swept up in that operation were
sitting that day so the process is very
much like commercial fishing right you
have the trawler that goes out and gets
the catch then they bring it back to the
factory ship where they get processed
further and then they bring them back to
the precinct where they actually become
canned fish and so on and so on getting
back to the bail question contrasting
that sort of that sort of trick that
they use to keep people in jail was a
case that I learned about that I that I
heard a lot of complaints about from
high-level prosecutors and this this is
a case called involving a company called
Jan REE or general reinsurance this was
a major target of Eliot Spitzer's back
in the mid-2000s Jan REE and AIG were
being accused of a 750 million dollar
stock fraud and the strategy that the
prosecutors wanted to employ was they
were going to go after some mid-level
players at Jan REE first convict them
throw them in jail and then get them to
roll on the higher higher ups at AIG
specifically they were going after the
CEO of the company at the time but they
got their convictions of the gen Reed
defendants but of course first of all
first of all none of these guys had bail
imposed on them that was high enough to
keep them in jail they all had huge
crowds of people come to their bail
hearings and would weep and tell the
judge that Oh Your Honor this is
somebody who wouldn't even jaywalk yes
he might commit a 750 million dollar
stock fraud but but
but jaywalking no and and the judges
didn't impose high bail but more than
that after they were convicted the
judges didn't even force them to go to
jail they allowed them all to stay out
and sleep in their own beds pending
appeal thus removing all the leverage
the state might have had to roll up
these these parties into more serious
targets at AIG so again this is just the
kind of contrast where you see ordinary
people who are just sort of tossed in
jail by the book and there's actually a
formula that they use to calculate how
much bail you get that's based upon how
many times you've been arrested whether
how many people show up in court to
support you that day whether you have
strong community ties whether you have a
job whether you have a telephone in your
house there's literally a formula so
there's a sort of long conga line of
defendants who come in for Street crimes
you come into court the judges doesn't
even look up half the time he simply
announces an amount of bail they get
sent to sent away the ones who can't
afford it get sent away and they end up
pleading you contrast that with the
situation with these high-level targets
who were at the time the most
significant targets in all of Wall
Street prosecution and that's that's
sort of a the difference in how bail is
employed bail is just simply not a
factor for people in involved in
white-collar crimes but it's an enormous
factor for everybody else another
another situation that's important to
talk about side-by-side is repeat
offenders there are no second chances
for people who commit things like crimes
like welfare fraud once you are caught
once you're out of the system forever
you will never get any other kind of
public assistance you'll lose your
ability to obtain professional licenses
members of your family may even be
thrown out of their homes if they have
section 8 housing there's a bizarre
anomaly in New York State where they
actually teach people in prison how to
cut hair
but when they get out they find out the
convicted criminals cannot get a
barber's license meanwhile on Wall
Street repeat offenders there's
absolutely no consequence to being a
repeat offender how many people here
heard of the HSBC case anybody so this
is a case a few years ago in which the
largest bank in Europe admitted to
laundering among other things
laundering 850 million dollars in drug
money for a pair of Central and South
American drug cartels the behavior was
so brazen that they actually had
specially fitted holes in the teller
windows for drug dealers to slide boxes
of cash through an HSBC had been warned
they had violated agreements not to
launder money over 30 times in the ten
years prior to that agreement and in
that agreement it was a deferred
prosecution agreement they paid a fine
not one person did one day in jail and
the only individual consequence for any
individual at the company was that some
of the executives had to defer their
bonuses for five years the New York
Times a few years ago did a story where
they found that there were 51 cases
involving 19 different Wall Street firms
who broke fraud statutes that they had
already promised not to break an example
would be Citigroup in 2011 which paid a
two hundred eighty five million dollar
fine to settle fraud charges and again
I'll get to this little in a moment but
the actual economic damage in that case
was much higher than two hundred eighty
five million dollars but they paid that
much but they have been sanctioned for
breaking exactly the same anti-fraud
statute in the year 2000 in 2005 and
2006 and in 2010 and each time they were
led off with a fine and once again they
were allowed to just promise that they
would never do it again and this is a
common common circumstance in
in Wall Street enforcement but again
contrast that with the ordinary street
criminal if you rob to let one liquor
store it's one thing if you rob to you
know you can imagine what the
consequences are fraud just to talk
about the difference between two kinds
of cases I know I already mentioned the
the single mom on welfare versus Angelo
Mozilo those are both fraud cases with
two radically different outcomes but
there's also the whole question of how
do you make a fraud case and I found out
that for instance when you apply for
welfare in states like California one of
the things you have to do is you have to
show up every quarter and sign a
document where it's basically it says I
the undersigned upon penalty of perjury
and other penalties attest that and then
you list all these things about your
life and you basically have to write
this mini biography every every three
months and what they're really looking
for is are you cohabiting with somebody
do you have assets that you're not
telling us about
do you have side work you're not telling
us about do you own a car that you're
not telling us about and so you have to
write down all these things and
everybody who is in the system knows
what answer you have to give in order to
get welfare as soon as you sign that
document it goes into the like this big
computer and it starts checking it
against all these different state
databases so if it happens that you say
that you don't have a car and you
suddenly apply for a driver's license
case is automatically generated or it
could be even more primitive than that
you could check a box saying I'm living
alone I don't have anybody staying at my
house and your neighbor may get a reward
for calling a tip line and saying that
yes my next-door neighbor had a man
staying at her house to two out of seven
days last week and that that can become
the genesis of a fraud case if you show
up at your welfare office and to talk to
your officer
and he or she sees you getting out
getting out of a car driven by a man
that can become the genesis of a fraud
case so basically what you're doing is
that a semi-regular basis here you're
saying I promise that all these things
about my life are true
and if you find any holes in my story
anywhere then then you can catch me for
fraud and I can lose custody of my kids
and etc etc and that's how it works
meanwhile on the other side of the coin
banks that were recipients of major
federal bailouts which of course are
another kind of welfare recipient we
don't even have the right to go into
those those companies and look in their
books half the time so it's a starkly
different situation where the state
claims the ability and the right to
invade your privacy almost that will if
you're a common welfare recipient but if
you're a major bailout recipient you
still maintain all the protections of a
corporation and as an individual you
will say you will never see any kind of
retribution for committing any kind of
fraud or almost never and you think and
you think about you know the
robo-signing cases I know I've been
going on and I'll get wrap it up quickly
but you know the robo-signing cases
those cases are all fraud I mean you
there and you could walk into any
courthouse you could go in in this city
and all you have to do is Google famous
Robo signers and you'll look at get a
list of names and just look for any
foreclosure documents in this in this
city and in the public courthouse and
you'll find cases of fraud it'll be a
situation where some person who purports
to be the vice-president of JP Morgan
Chase or Wells Fargo in fact it's always
like a 23 year old pimply kid that they
just hired who is given this title and
he says I attest that I have that I've
had personal knowledge of this home loan
from the beginning they filed this
affidavit to the court when they want to
foreclose upon someone in reality that
kid signed a thousand of those documents
that day he doesn't have any
personal analogy of anything that's
fraud but nobody ever does anything
about that it's kind of like the movie
The Untouchables where you know Sean
Connery says it's not like we don't know
where the liquor is we just did we just
did it's a question of whether or not
we're gonna you know arrest the people
for bringing it in or not and you know
he goes into the post office and he
arrests all those folks for for bringing
in liquor in Chicago it's the same thing
here and the last thing I want to talk
about is this restitution and just
really quickly restitution in street
cases is always at least a hundred
percent again not to drove it to go on
about the welfare thing but if you get
caught for welfare fraud and it's a
eight hundred dollar case you're gonna
pay $800 minimum that's how much that's
how much the restitution is going to be
I am I interviewed one man who actually
under the California 3 strikes provision
he was sentenced to life in jail for
stealing a two dollar and fifty cent
pair of tube socks and his restitution
was somewhere north of $11,000 in order
to pay that off he had to work in a
prison cafeteria every day of his life
for 17 years until his sentence was was
finally commuted last year and at the
time of his release he still had not
paid off
the restitution on those socks meanwhile
if you look at these sentences these
settlements involving these Wall Street
companies if you see a billion dollar
settlement you can bet that the profit
was thirty billion dollars or if you see
chase like for instance last year
settling for twenty billion dollars
which they did for a variety of offenses
you can bet that they made an awful lot
more money than that in fact that only
turned out to be about half of the
bank's net last year so it even though
it gave them a bad year last year it
wasn't even enough to puncture the banks
bottom line for for even a single year
and so this sort of speaks to
a wider problem which is that we just
look at these two different kinds of
offenders differently I remember early
on in this process talking to a federal
prosecutor and I talked about this on a
daily show and saying I was talking
about a company like countrywide and I
was saying how is it these guys are not
in jail you know they're they're perfect
symbols of everything that went wrong
they caused billions of dollars in
damage they committed fraud you've got
them dead to rights you got documentary
evidence why aren't they in jail and the
guy says to me is like have you been to
a jail jails are dangerous you know like
people get stabbed in jail and you know
I'm not disagreeing with you but you
have to and I had 2.2 million people in
jail in this country and it was just
it's the mentality that wall of jail is
just not the right resolution for this
kind of offender but it is the right
resolution for another kind of offender
and that's a dangerous situation for us
to be in and just sort of lastly this
the last thing I want to talk about is
collateral consequences which is this
doctrine that was invented by our
current Attorney General Eric Holder
back when he was the Deputy Attorney
General in the Clinton administration in
the late 90s he wrote this thing that
came to be known as affectionately as to
Holder memo and in it he outlined this
policy called collateral consequences
and all collateral consequences said was
that if you're a prosecutor and you are
worried about the innocent victims of a
prosecution of a major company like for
instance the shareholders or maybe
executives who weren't guilty of the
wrongdoing like for instance an HSBC the
guys who weren't laundering money for
drug dealers right if you're worried
about them if you're worried about the
community where the company might have
its headquarters you may seek other
remedies like fines like non-prosecution
agreement Slyke deferred prosecution
agreements and this is a sensible policy
you don't always want to wreck a company
just because a few bad apples might have
been
turn money for the for you know
narco-terrorists or whatever it is but
what they've done now is that conflated
that policy with another policy which is
not to even proceed against the
individuals of these firms so while you
may understand not filing a criminal
account against the company because that
can have devastating consequences for
any company even one as big as HSBC
they've they've decided apparently and
they won't say this openly but but you
can see it by their actions that they're
not also they're also not going to move
against the individuals at these firms
and to me this this speaks to a
psychological moment in our history
where it's not only are these companies
too big too big to jail but their
executives are increasingly viewed by
the people in the Justice Department and
in our law enforcement structure as
being just not the right kind of people
who go to jail for jail like there are
certain kinds of people who are going to
pay fines and then there's other kinds
of people who can handle are going to
those dirty dangerous jails where people
get stabbed and that is just a very
dangerous place for us to be and and
that's what this book is about and I I
hope it has some kind of impact and and
I hope you if you've bought the book I
hope you enjoy it and I'm happy to take
any questions for each firm for you
okay so when you started you said that
you've been giving it another version of
a talk speech and then you said you
threw it out this morning and you
decided to give us the honest version so
I want to know what the dishonest
version I just left out the part about
how I just left out the fact that I mean
there's there there's an undercurrent of
this book that's actually kind of
ridiculous if you're paying close
attention that this is this is a story
about a middle-aged white man who just
didn't know that that poor people can go
to jail really easily and that's kind of
pathetic actually and all I really want
was trying to say is that I should have
copped to that more and in the in the
text and that that this is part of the
reason why the book is kind of is
written in this scattershot fashion it
there are a lot of these kind of bursts
of outrage mixed with you know analysis
and you know I just I should have been
more open about this in the text that
this was a this was something that I
should i personally should have been
ashamed of is that I didn't know all
this stuff beforehand as a reporter and
so I'm trying as best I can to try to
tell that story a little bit more
because that's that's definitely in the
background of this of this story all
right Matt my name is Chris Toby I
worked with you on a pension story right
yes Sonnen and I just wanted to ask you
about you know what can people do about
I mean I'm real disappointed that the
media in general has not picked up a lot
of stories I've been trying to talk to
them about and you have in a few others
no thank you for that what can the
people in this room do to get the you
know our local media our local
politicians more involved and start to
you know to get engaged and start to
looking some these issues well I think
that's a great question Chris it's hard
you know I get asked the solutions
question a lot and I'm not great at it
I know for instance on the question of
of too big to fail and and what are we
going to do about these companies that
are so big that we can't prosecute them
well the obvious answer that even the
Chiefs of most of the Federal Reserve
branches in this country have come to is
that we have to break up these companies
now how do we how do we yes right if
you're too big to jail if you're too big
to fail you're too big to exist there's
just no other way around that and these
companies enjoy basically implicit
federal federal backing and the funny
thing about this for me is that you know
I'm probably thought of as a politically
very left person the progressive person
but actually this experience of doing
this story has pushed me maybe me a
little bit more in the other direction
where I think the fastest way for all
this stuff to resolve itself is to get
us back to a situation where these
companies are small enough where if
they're corrupt if they're stupid if
they do wrong things then we can just
let them go down the drain of history
which is what we didn't do in 2008 and
there's a growing some sentiment in
government towards making this happen
somehow there's there are bills that are
being sponsored by people like sherrod
Brown in Ohio yes thank you to to break
up these companies but I think it
honestly it's going to take another
gigantic Cataclysm for us to get there
there were a lot of people in Congress
who will tell you privately that
intellectually they're there already
they agree but it's a huge step for a
member of Congress to take to decide to
cut himself off from all the money from
from Chase and Goldman and all those
salt and Bank of America and so on and
that's what it would take a sacrifice
and asking politicians to make a
sacrifice is generally a fruitless
endeavor so but I you know I have I have
some hope that that will happen and I
think that's that's one important thing
that I think we can all that people
should be lobbying for they should be
pressuring their elected representatives
to think about and so on
thank you a few years ago Ron Paul
introduced legislation to either abolish
the Federal Reserve or to audit it and a
House subcommittee had a hearing about
the Federal Reserve and they had
somebody in the witness stand who was
responsible for over watching the
Federal Reserve and she testified that
there were several trillion dollars
missing mm-hmm and I saw the videotape
on YouTube and I haven't heard anything
else about that well I mean it doesn't
really matter whether there's money
missing from the feds and so they can
just create money anyway so but I
completely supported actually Ron Paul's
efforts to audit the Fed I at the time I
knew I knew a lot about it because he
worked with Bernie Sanders on that bill
the audit of the Fed revealed
extraordinary information about the
bailout because most people only know
about the seven hundred billion dollar
tarp bailout right that's that's what
they that's what we hear about when they
when they talk about the bailout right
but it turns out that in addition to
that seven hundred billion dollars there
were also sixteen trillion dollars in
essentially zero interest loan emergency
loans that were handed out to all these
companies at that time now we're in
another situation where the Fed is is
propping up the economy through the
quantitative easing program which is
pumping forty five billion dollars of
money into the into the financial sector
every month which is having all kinds of
strange consequences because without
getting too wonky about this what QE
really does is it buys up all the safe
stuff and it forces investors to seek
yield elsewhere so rather than simply
collecting savings and interest as you
might have in the past now you got to
emerge in Brazilian mergers or
or you have to invest in the stock
market or in something riskier than you
did before and so it's creating
artificially creating all this this
risk-taking behavior the banks are
making a fortune because it all this
investment money that's pouring into all
these different places well if you if
now as a result of that you're having
mergers in Brazil and India and places
like that who do you think is doing
those mergers it's all these all these
companies so it's like a welfare program
for all these firms so they're using all
these trillions of dollars to buy up
other companies well they're using all
the the the trillions of dollars let's
just say are artificially propping up a
lot of things including the bottom lines
of a lot of these firms including and
everybody is deeply concerned what's
gonna happen when they term it when they
turn that spigot off and we you know
they're worried about what they call the
taper when they taper off this this
ongoing welfare program and there were
either bubble might burst so I think the
Fed is something that people have to
learn about more they have to learn
about its role it's it's a strange kind
of extra democratic force in all of our
lives I think people on both the left
and the right have a common interest in
understanding what's going on there and
so it's a good question and but as to
permanently auditing the Fed it took
like a hundred years or 80 years to even
get that little sliver that they got I
wouldn't hold my breath waiting to find
out what happened to that money you
sound like a gold hello mister TV it's
Matt I'm sorry I I'm I'm a young
journalist and I'm sorry and I'm doing
my best to bring awareness I'm I'm
currently a news correspondent for a
non-for-profit and I'm trying to do my
best but to be honest I mean I feel
extremely powerless not an individual
and I'm doing my best as to try to bring
awareness try to
form people and I've done my research
and I've the only thing I can think of
doing because I know like you said on
the daily show my mom and I watched it
last night mm-hmm that it's a fixture
that this system is it's almost it's
almost necessary impossible to a tackle
but you have to work from the ground up
mm-hmm and to basically we're trying to
you know get the power back for the
common man right even though that kind
of sounds like you've been accused of
being a communist and stuff like that
you start talking about that it some
people get edgy about it but what are
you thoughts
where are your thoughts on a workplace
democracy and because it's I've seen
like some I think it's an organization
called Simcoe and there's these
different organizations that have
basically like have open transparency do
profit sharing their employees and they
allow themselves to have different
models where they elect their employers
in the sense they feel like they can
actually be a part of the system and I
just wanted to know what you what your
thoughts on that I'm all for that
amazing night hopefully I think that's
what my new company is all about I mean
I don't know exactly yet but I think
it's always good when people take
ownership in what they do I think it's
actually and again this gets back to the
whole thing of being more of a
capitalist than I used to be I think
it's also just good business people when
people care about they have a stake in
what they're doing they tend to do a
better job they tend to stay later they
tend to put more of their creative
energies into things and samel for that
and you know as despairing about being a
journalist and worrying about whether or
not you're having an impact just don't
worry about that that's it's not your
job to like worry about changing the
world is just you know I grew up around
journalists my whole life your job is
just to you know do what you do and just
make sure that you're not lying when you
do it and make sure to catch people when
they are lying and that's that's an
important public service already if
you're just doing that and it's more
than most journalists do so
you know don't don't get down on
yourself thank you hello um we've all
been reading about issues like this for
the last since 2008 at least and it's
almost as if the Wall Street tycoon and
the poor black kid in New York with a
joint in its pocket they're almost like
caricatures right everybody in between
them cities like Louisville or Provo
Utah or Jacksonville Florida sure what
do we look for to to see if that's
happening in our midst as well well
there's a couple of things first of all
it's a good question I get that question
all the time well I'm in the middle
class so this doesn't matter to me
that's actually there's a couple of
things first of all here in the middle
class you're definitely or very likely
to have been a victim of white-collar
crime by the financial services sector
if you own a pension you you how many
people here have a pension anybody
anybody lose money after 2008 yeah okay
so that was very likely
I mean fraud played a huge role in the
in in the what happened to pension funds
after 2008 if you have a credit card if
you have a mortgage if you have any kind
of floating rate investment you were
affected when the bank started monkeying
around with the London interbank offered
rate or LIBOR which was basically a
gigantic antitrust case where they were
playing around with world interest rates
to suit their needs if you bought a can
of beer or a can of soda in the last
four or five years you may you were
affected because there's been
manipulation in the metals markets
aluminium zinc copper there's been
manipulation of foreign currency rates
so if you have savings and dollars you
are savings in another currency you
might have been affected if you have
just a savings account you've been
affected by the bailouts and by the by
the Fed policy because you're no longer
earning as much interest as you said
there are a lot of people who are
elderly who used to live off their CD
income who can't do that anymore because
there's no one come to be had anymore
because interest rates have been slashed
to nothing and so people in the middle
are affected by all these things and
then and on the Justice side I would
argue that you know you know I
interviewed people in this book who
became victims of police abuse when
because like anything else stop and
frisk sort of ran out of its normal
cache of victims and started fanning out
into other neighborhoods and other types
of targets not that I'm not saying that
that's likely to happen anybody in this
room but I think it's just important
that we all learn about what's going on
and you know 2.2 million people in the
prison system here in America that's
that's a major national crisis whether
you're whether you have a relative in
prison or not that's the biggest prison
population in the history of human
civilization something weird is going on
especially since crime is declining and
we all need to learn about it i husband
excuse me I was wondering if there's a
when you speak of restitution I was
wondering if there was difference on how
often that money is collected and if
that money where that money actually
goes that's a good question like in the
case of the the settlements from what I
understand when they collects elements
like the hsbc settlement that money
basically ends up in the budgets of the
regulatory agencies so good for them but
and again this is part of the argument
they always give you they say well we
could fight them for ten years in
Criminal Court and lose and not get
anything or they can give us two billion
dollars tomorrow and think of all the
good that we can do with that money
and I'm like well am I getting any of
that money I mean you know the victim
because why do we put people in jail
first of all is this good this goes back
to that question because I had to ask
this question for this book and you know
a lot for one law professor told me it's
really for three reasons one is
deterrence to the individual it stops
the individual from doing it again of
course that would be very true with this
community offenders deterrence to the
group and also again would be very
effective with this kind of offender and
the third thing is justice for victims
so you know even if you've if you've
been the victim of fraud if you've been
the victim of a financial crime the
reason one of the reasons to put
somebody in prison is because you know
the victim should get justice well are
the victims getting justice when they
collect fines I'm not seeing that I mean
in the case of the foreclosure fraud
settlement some of that money did end up
going towards helping people in
foreclosure but that's not typical
that's not a typical resolution
typically the money sort of disappears
into the ether of the enforcement
budgets and it's not really clear who
gains from it other than the people who
concluded the settlement in fact many
times a class action private class
action lawyers will complain that the
government rushing in and making those
settlements prevents them from also
getting settlements out of the same
group of actors so that the the private
claimants the victims who bring in a
private suit there's less left over for
them so the in fact sometimes those
settlements actually work against the
victims of these crimes and that I have
two questions number one are you Mike
Thai eby's brother is or
many years ago professor at City College
of New York world book called rich in
the super-rich mm-hmm and in it he said
that one of the problems of our tax
system is that so many of the loopholes
are for the rich and obviously the poor
have no much income to be taxed anyway
right that you know we're definitely
leading toward a plutocracy and he wrote
this book back in the 50s right and do
you think that that's true
oh yeah and okay if if it is true what
are the chances of people like us in a
suit against the corporation for example
in private liability
our credit card manipulation or
monopolist or monopolistic practices
that you know they don't enforce the
antitrust laws anymore
well there have been a lot of successful
private class-action lawsuits that's a
good question and the for instance with
the subprime mortgage fraud stuff while
there have been no criminal cases really
on any of that there have been a lot of
private class-action suits that have
been filed by say you know state pension
funds or city funds or foreign hedge
funds and they've they want some money
back I mean a lot of these companies
have been seriously dinged by that and
so if you are a victim of that kind of
thing then you have a decent chance
especially since one of the features of
this whole era is that the nobody
communicates anymore without texting or
I or I am I
grotesque conspiracies and in writing
everywhere so when it comes time to
actually sue these people it turns out
to be pretty easy sport for a lot of
them but and just as quickly I know I
know everybody's got to go but they
answer your tax question I mean come on
when when Mitt Romney pays a maximum
10% rate on his private equity work and
you know a fireman is whatever 20 25
percent for his income something is
seriously wrong I mean most of these
people are not paying anywhere close
they have a tiny amount of what you
would call income and everything else is
either capital gains or carried interest
and that's just a scam and so it has to
be fixed thank you thank you thank you
very much
it seems to be that the local police
forces weather in New York City or even
here don't seem to be doing their job
mentally in terms of protecting and
serving it just seems like they're being
used as pawns also the police yeah to
spread nets that just capture up people
so I'm wondering what what do you
perceive that is there that sort of
mentality that we're working with now in
the United States I think you know there
are a lot of frustration and I know
everybody's got to go there are a lot of
frustrated policemen by this statistics
based system it's it's an it's a numbing
ly inefficient way to do things
cops don't have the leeway that they
want it they have but to make quality
cases anymore they got it they got to
write tickets they hate it for the most
part and the people who tend to rise in
the system are the few who enjoy it and
they tend to be the sadistic dumb ones
and and that's a problem I think you
know there's there's been a like in many
professions there's been a de-emphasis
of appreciation for the person who
actually knows how to do the job and
more of an emphasis on the person who is
able to deliver the stats and I think in
that that's a huge problem I think we
got it we got to stop now right is that
correct okay thanks thanks very much